have you ever wondered why roman and
greek sculptures are whites
well the answer may seem obvious that's
because gypsum the material they're made
of is white
but for cambridge university classics
faculty the question hangs in the air
they plan to put up signs next to the
white plaster cast explaining why they
are not diverse in color
the university claims that the current
display gives a misleading impression of
the whiteness of the ancient world
the plaster cast collection of the
museum of classical archaeology both
from the cast gallery and distributed
around the lecture rooms of the faculty
building gives a misleading impression
about the whiteness and absence of
diversity from the greek and roman world
but highlighting the diversity of the
ancient world may come as a challenge
mainly because the museum's 600 piece
collection of roman and greek casts is
primarily a depiction of well roman and
greeks a song is a story history you
know is uh it is impossible to offend
anyone
also we are talking about some things
made years years ago so it doesn't make
any difference what now is the message
but you have to always refer what was
the message back at that stage i think
it's a great decision i think any
decision to explain
previous cultures and justify their
decisions is a good one
are the most of the sculptures here are
plastic casts anyway then
plaster is white
for for most open-minded people you know
people discolor things they turn things
white
if it isn't it's true representation
then maybe it's it's useful for those
who are particularly concerned about it
to have a plaque suggesting so
i don't think it's offensive personally
if it's just like the way the material
is and especially if they were painted
have just faded like what can you do
about it you don't really paint
a picasso would you just because it
faded the university's decision to
present these signs comes in response to
a letter signed by thousands of students
staff and alumi the letter calls for
public acknowledgement of racism within
classics and the need for anti-racist
works with the discipline the new action
plan also calls on classic faculty
members to receive an implicit bias
training every three years the plaques
explaining the whiteness of gypsum casts
are due to go on display later this year
and one may only wonder what will be
written on them there was diversity in
ancient greece and rome but you you
can't
have diversity among statues which are
made out of plaster cast this obsession
people have with identity has meant that
um
the university has fallen into line with
radical left-wing
theories instead of paying attention to
what actually happened in ancient greece
ranch in rome
their minds would be distracted by
contemporary political gobbledygook it's
not useful at all
it's it's a waste of time it's a waste
of money and why should you have to
explain to any anyone apart from an
idiot
that a plaster cast is going to be white
it means just a fact of nature which
everybody understands and for the
university of cambridge to degrade
itself in this way
and act as if
all members of its staff and student
body and all visitors have to be treated
as idiots it seems to me to be
absolutely deplorable
you